white house is signaling progress on a
new round of coronavirus relief
the administration says president trump
has approved a revised package
and treasury secretary steve mnuchin
will be talking with speaker pelosi
later this afternoon fox business
network's blake berman reporting on this
news that's breaking now blake the
latest
hi there yeah hi there harris it was a
pretty big announcement from larry
kudlow when he appeared on fox business
earlier today saying
that the president had recently sat down
in the oval office
with the treasury secretary steve
mnuchin and the white house chief of
staff and gave the green light to go
ahead
on a new plan for covid relief a senior
administration official has since told
me
the new top line number from the white
house is 1.8 trillion dollars
meaning that the white house has come
upwards a couple hundred billion dollars
from the 1.5
1.6 trillion that they had previously
been at
kudlow also said that will be the topic
of conversation when mnuchin
has a phone call later today with the
speaker of the house
nancy pelosi now as kudlow was unveiling
all of this
president trump then took to twitter and
he wrote the following he said quote
covid relief negotiations are moving
along go
big this right here was the very broad
outline that kudlow talked about
as it relates to the white house offer i
think
this package is going to include
what our white house asks have been
with respect to airline assistance
to small business ppp assistants
probably i can't swear to this there'll
be some backup for
unemployment assistance exactly the
things that i've argued
will help the recovery
but keep in mind harris this 1.8
trillion dollar offer from the white
house still
well short of the 2.2 trillion dollars
that nancy pelosi feels
is needed she also thinks that the white
house has the complete
wrong mindset when it comes to tackling
covid19 this was part of what she wrote
to her democratic colleagues in a letter
earlier today she said quote clearly and
sadly the administration
does not share this priority of crushing
the virus the president does not have
the capacity leadership or plan for
testing tracing
and isolation that is needed instead she
writes trump's delay denial distortion
of reality and disdain for science has
exacted
a deadly and preventable human toll we
should note as well harris that in
kentucky today
the senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell said that there were still
vast differences
to be negotiated out here and he also
said that he does not believe
that something can come together between
now and election day
the white house bottom line moving its
number up
but still a very long way to go here
harris
well look often times when they have
these discussions real quickly blake i
want to get your take on this
you'll see some reverb on the markets
are we anticipating that
there was a bounce you could literally
watch it as larry kudlow was talking
uh on fox business this morning don't
quote me to the to the exact number here
but it was like
the dow was up 100 and by the the end of
that interview was it was like up 200 or
something like that
they saw that the headline and it was
something that the market loved clearly
if the white house is coming up
investors are going to look at that and
say maybe there's some hope
but as you know you always have to look
under the headline
which is why i say here there's still a
long way to go
all right blake berman good to see you
thank you